so sam harris recently did an interview
that has been a little viral that has
been going uh being shared clips all
over the place and most people are
sharing a part of the video where he
talks about trump and the uh the biden
laptop and uh that's not really what
interests me so much i'm sure a lot of
people will be commenting on that but
there's another little clip that is
being shared in which uh sam harris
says that he's not going to make magical
claims about a flying savior
um you know coming down from heaven and
where is heaven exactly given that we
have all these telescopes that are
beaming back information from millions
of years ago uh and so i i was really
surprised to see something like that i
mean i had
i thought that
i thought that
sam heiress would have the generosity to
address things at the highest level of
what it is that he's criticizing but uh
i reacted and said on twitter well this
is the one one of the most embarrassing
things i've heard in a while but after i
tweeted that i thought about it a little
bit
and i started to think that maybe
i should be a little more generous to
sam harris because
there are people there are people that
think ex that think heaven is something
like what sam he is
suggesting it is
and so i thought that it might be a good
idea to maybe
address what is heaven where is heaven
what it is that we're talking about when
we were talking about this and also why
maybe some people
will have a more
we'll tend towards a more literalist
interpretation of that and why and what
that could mean even that so let's go
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
so in order to
understand what heaven and earth is you
really have to be able
to step into
an ancient person's perception you know
you really have to be able to step back
into an ancient cosmology and so you can
tell me that ancient cosmologies are
stupid that they're ridiculous that
they're disproven you know then fine but
you're not going to be able to
understand what they're talking about so
there is a way to enter into
this perception and we can we can talk
about it as you know recapturing a
phenomenological point of view that is
recapturing the this experience of the
world that we have as revealing being to
us in the way that that martin heidegger
talks about and if we do that then we
can
more easily recapture what it is that
the ancients were talking about when
they use the term
a heaven and earth um
and what we'll realize is that these
categories of heaven and earth they are
universal in
every culture
sometimes they are personified as gods
like uranus and gaya or in for example
native traditions you'll have father
heaven mother earth you have it in a
more abstract sometimes more
philosophical way in chinese theory you
have yang and yin as heaven and earth
and you see it again like i said in
scripture at the beginning in genesis 1
god creates heaven and earth now if you
want to understand what heaven is you
have to understand
that it's related to what it says right
there at the outset god create heaven
and earth the earth was empty and void
it was dark and empty and void and then
from heaven comes things that help you
see the world what comes at first it
come there comes speech god speaks the
world into existence god creates light
light which makes you makes it possible
for you to see things
and then he creates hierarchies out of
heaven and so it's not that difficult to
kind of understand what heaven is in
terms of
its highest meaning it's
from heaven comes that which makes it
possible
for identities to exist that is light
comes down from heaven and and it you
can't see light
but light makes it possible for you to
see other things so you can't see wind
but wind
is the animating thing that keeps you
alive you can't see wind but wind moves
the trees and moves things around you
invisibly and so
what come what is heaven is something
like
the invisible hierarchy which
underlies the world it is that's why
it's speech that's why it's light that's
why it's breath that's why it's spirit
and so it is
the invisible things that make other
things move is the best way to maybe
understand that and so a lot of
materialists will say well you know we
don't believe in that stuff we we don't
believe in invisible we just we don't
believe in the invisible world the
supernatural world white you a lot of
materialists tend to call it but usually
the reason why they struggle so much
with the notion of supernatural because
the imagine supernatural as something
which just has a different like
invisible substance i guess which is
like the material world but is invisible
uh and that is not at all what the
ancients meant when they talked about
the idea of the invisible world or the
or or the world or heaven or spirit
you know what they meant by it were
things that were really invisible that
is patterns meanings
purposes
math proportions all of these things are
not visible that is you can have
instantiations of them but they're not
visible as such so you can't see a
purpose a purpose is an invisible motor
which makes things move you can't see
a pattern but you can see its
instantiations in the world and so
you know that that's true that the
pattern is exist in a different way than
let's say the thing in which you find it
so take a
take an apple for example you can
recognize an apple
and if the pattern was completely in
that apple
then you could recognize that this is
also an apple and this and this and this
so you couldn't be able to see apples
across many different instantiations of
apples if there wasn't a man in which
the pattern of apple
exists in a different in a different way
it exists in a causal way it exists in a
way that causes you causes things to
bind together
and exist as phenomena that you can
recognize
and so that is what heaven is and then
earth is
the potentiality it's the visible world
it's the world of instantiation
but it's the world of the multiple
whereas
heaven is moving towards the one moving
towards the purpose moving towards the
reason for things uh you know the matter
in which they kind of move into one
that's why heaven is often represented
as a as a ladder right if the story of
jacob's ladder you have a ladder going
up and you have angels going up and down
it can be represented as a tree as this
hierarchy of structure going up
or it can be recognized as you know it's
often instantiated as something like you
know going up a mountain for example is
a way to instantiate it's not heaven
itself of course a tree is in heaven and
a mountain is in heaven but it's like
the it's the the place on earth which
can help you understand
as much as possible what heaven is and
so
what's interesting is that a lot of
people will think that maybe we're just
like projecting back into these ancient
ways of thinking of course the ancient
people didn't think that way they were
just stupid and they were
they were materialists like us but they
weren't i don't know what to tell you
you know and and some people started to
have an intuition of this um
quite you know in in the the last late
20th century or mid 20th century going
on you see that for example martin
heidegger i'm going to read a little
text from you
in his origin of the work of art
he he he realizes in reading aristotle
and reading the ancients and when when
they talk about earth they're not
talking about a planet they're talking
about
this lower
let's say this quantity this
potentiality at the bottom of the world
out of which phenomena arises and so he
says
what this word earth means here is far
removed from the idea of a mass of
matter and from the merely astronomical
idea of a planet earth is that in which
the arising of everything that arises is
brought back as indeed the very thing
that it is and sheltered in the things
that arise the earth presences as the
protecting one so the idea is that let's
say
you can understand the earth as this
matrix out of which phenomena arises but
also in a certain way earth is that
which protects so the phenomena is that
which protects this these things keeps
them together or also holds them let's
say
in potentiality so that they come back
up so i mean obviously he's he's
definitely talking about
something like a seed falling in the
ground or you know seed falling in the
ground and king being kept
underground and then
coming up using the earth to then arise
out of it and then it will go back into
the earth but this is this is not a
materialist way of thinking it's it's it
could be true of of anything right of
any type of structure that arises out of
potentiality that finds a structured
form and then ultimately will go back
into that potentiality because
everything comes and goes nothing is is
immortal everything has a time comes up
and then goes back into potentiality and
then comes back and then something else
will come back up that will have a
similar pattern not exactly the same and
so heidegger understood very well that
when we talk about earth we're not
talking about this planet or the stuff
that's on the ground although we'll see
how it's related he was that that that
aristotle was talking about this these
two categories of of heaven and earth of
that which is above that which is below
this is something which was understood
by ancients i could find many many
examples but i want to read from you an
example from dante and so dante does a
very beautiful things
um
and so in the paradisio in kanto 29 uh
beatrice who's guiding him up now these
heavenly spheres and so this is when
he's reached the top he's reached the
prime mobile which if you think about
the spheres of heaven as we experience
them we have that these planets that
cross the
the heavens and they have different
levels so you know the highest one is
saturn
the lowest one is the moon of course and
then there are all these planetary
these these these planets that go up and
create like a ladder of of a hierarchy
so in in dante's story dante will climb
those spheres
as a ladder of perfection and so
as he goes up
he will encounter souls that are more
finer and finer that encompassing them
more and more good
uh until he reaches the very top and
then he will be brought into the
presence of god himself and so you can
think oh my goodness like what a silly
what a silly way of thinking right
because i'd like to take sam's position
like there's satellites up there did
they get in the way of dante like did he
knock himself on the satellites while he
was going up the spheres
but dante's is writing at an interesting
time because he's writing at a time
where i think that he sensed that there
was a deep change of foot and that let's
say the great medieval synthesis of of
metaphysics and religion was
coming to an end and that he almost had
to
warn his readers about not
reading what he was saying in the wrong
way because sometimes
in old text one of the reasons why they
don't interpret it for you is because
they take for granted that you're not an
idiot if you're reading these texts and
that you would understand it but i think
dante is is a little keen on on putting
in a little more in there for you to
understand and so
and so what oh no now sorry i'm going to
read you first with something that that
beatrice tells him when he is at the
lowest sphere and he's getting ready now
to ascend these fears and to encounter
these souls and so beatrice says
so beatrice explained to dante right
standing at this lowest level of the
heavenly sphere he's about to ascend the
spheres and encounter these different
purified souls souls that have reached
more and more good more and more purpose
more and more meaning as they are
you know as they are higher up in the
heavens and so
so beatrice says that
these souls showed themselves here not
because allotted this fear has been to
them but to give sign of the celestial
which is least exalted
at that lowest sphere of heaven
to speak thus is adapted to your mind
since only through the sense it
apprehends what then it worthy makes of
intellect
on this account the scripture
condescends unto your faculties and
feats and hands to god attributes and
means something else
and holy church under an aspect of human
gabriel and michael represent to you and
him who made tobias whole again and so
it's saying
the souls the souls aren't in these
heavenly spheres my goodness are you an
idiot like the souls don't live in these
planetary spheres
but your experience of these fears
they are the proper analogy and and
we are using this language of
hierarchies of heavens that you are
encountering as the proper way to help
you understand the hierarchy of souls
and the hierarchy of purified beings and
of qualities that ascend up to the good
um
and so it's like you only we only first
understand things through our senses and
then those senses our refined experience
of our senses is what helps us reach the
abstract or helped us reach the more
spiritual intuitions but it starts
grounded in our
our our most immediate
encounters our our sensual experiences
are the ground on which these more
spiritual or even just abstract uh
intuitions are built and this is
something i think
even a materialist should understand
right um
and so then it says you know we
represent these angels as having wings
guys with wings but we know that that's
not what they are we we say god is hands
and feet and god has a nose and
everything but we're not saying that god
is a big physical being in the sky that
has these attributes like no one no one
that that that has
a subtle understanding of these things
would think that okay
and so beatrice is warning him not to
fall into that trap and then she she so
later now when we get to the top to the
prime mobile then she does exactly what
it is that i've been saying she does she
links exactly
the ancient philosophical categories
like the ancient aristotelian
separation between act and potential
with heaven and earth and so she says
order was concreted and constructed in
substances and summit of the world
were those wherein the pure act was
produced
pure potentiality held the lowest part
and midway
bound potentiality with act such bond
that it shall never be unbound so it
says
the world is is constructed in in these
essences in these meanings these
purposes these these
these patterns
that encompass more and more of the good
and at the top is
pure act and at the bottom
earth is pure potentiality and in the
middle of course she's talking about the
incarnation as the place in which man
as the the one that gathers visibili the
visible into him but also gathers the
invisible because man is the only one at
least that we know of that is capable of
abstract thought that is capable of of
representing the good of of perceiving
the good it's itself or perceiving the
trail that leads up to the good itself
and so man is that place where
act you know and christ is the ultimate
version of that where potentiality and
act are bound in a way that you'll never
be unbound and so
beatrice is joining
the very basic metaphysical categories
with heaven and earth in a way that
would not have surprised anybody in the
middle ages not at all like this would
have been completely normal this is what
heaven
and earth are
and so the question is why do we use
these particular images and this is
where you know i think it's important to
understand that
the images are also not arbitrary so the
fact that we talk about something which
is above
as being akin to heaven or helping us
understand what heaven is
is not something that could be replaced
with anything because our experience of
that which is above us is
the best analogy that we can find in our
senses
to represent analogically the experience
of something which is higher
in terms of
this pattern these patterns of being
that lay themselves out and so think
about it just like in a in a in a simple
experiment this is a this is an
experiment that my brother met here uh
thought of a long time ago and and it
was just such a great insight that he
had he said if you're in a crowd of
people
and someone stands up in a chair
what happens something happens
all of a sudden everybody in that crowd
can see that person
the person that is above can see
everybody in the crowd
but the people in the crowd can't see
all of they can't see all of each other
they can only see the people that are
just next to them
and so moving up physically moving up in
the world
is moving from the multiple into the one
it is having an experience which
contains more quantity into a single
vision
and this is why in scripture that's the
same thing of why
moses goes up a mountain to encounter
god
you know and try it like do it you can
see it you know if you let's say you lay
down on the ground and look look around
what do you see not much you'll see some
bunch of blades of grass
you'll see some maybe a few bugs if
you're lucky
but then stand up and start walking up a
hill walking up a mountain and once you
when you walk up the mountain what's
going to happen is that more and more
quantity of information is going to be
gathered into one it's going to be
gathered into that which binds it
together
and if you reach the very top of the
mountain then all of a sudden you have a
perception of of this
whole map
and so you can have an
experience of all of this space which is
gathered into a single vision so you can
understand that that is what
moving up into heaven is it's moving up
from the quantity into the quality from
the body into the purpose or into the
head or into the thing which binds the
body together and you can see it
in any kind of phenomena that you want
right if you're
if you're i always use a sports team and
as an example but it's a good example
like if you're in a sports team you know
you have all the players and then you
have the captain of the team or the the
the you know the captain of the team
gives the
the plan for the play and the bod and
the all the players will embody the
different aspects of the plan but the
plan comes from above the plan comes
from the captain which stands above the
other players and eve you know and if he
wants to talk to all of them he actually
will have to stand above he'll have to
either stand in front in a way where
they can all see him he's going to have
to stand on a chair or he's going to be
in the middle where everybody can see
him because
he is the one giving the plan for the
other so that they can now embody that
plan in the world so you could say that
fractally at a lower level at a
microcosmic level the captain of the
team ascends into heaven or ascends at
least to the top of the mountain to to
receive the plan from heaven and then
gives that plan
to the team players and then the team
players embody that plan in the actual
play in the game and so that can that is
a very good way for you to understand
what heaven is and so when the bible or
when you see in in scripture people
ascend into heaven it it doesn't it
doesn't mean the same thing
as a lot of people seem to think it
means it means that it means going up
the hierarchy of principalities and
becoming
a cause or a light that shines light on
multiple
multiple things and so you can
understand it like
like a king or a president or you know
uh someone who who's the the originator
of
something who's the first one and so it
he kind of blazed away and everybody
kind of follows in
in their their path that is a good way a
good analogy to kind of understand
heaven
so you can understand that when we say
that someone ascends into heaven means
that they move up this hierarchy of
causality and they become like
principles for the whole world and so
the idea like if you say something like
jesus is in heaven well of course jesus
is in heaven i mean jesus is the cause
of pretty much a very very large person
of western civilization and so he is a
prince the principle that holds western
civilization even as a secularist you
would have to see that you would have to
see that there's some figures rise up
into heaven and then
cause
other people to to to follow in their
wake or to to to look to them as lights
and examples and patterns to follow um
and that of course in the in the
christian sense has a as a very deep and
profound meaning and it means that you
can this is something that can actually
happen that's why we have patron saints
that's why you have patron saints of
whole phenomenas of being and you have
patron saints of places paint you name
places after after
beings that have ins you could say
ascended into heaven is the best way to
describe that
and so
so the thing is that
this is going to be maybe the most
difficult part for people to understand
is that the analogy of heaven that we
understand
is the proper analogy that is the actual
physical experience of things that are
above you
is the best analogy for that and so
that's why it's used to describe what's
what what the scripture is talking about
now what's going to happen
is that not everybody will be capable of
understanding act and potential not
everybody is going to be able to
understand the relationship between the
invisible and the visible the
relationship between the patterns the
purpose and their instantiations and
some people like your great aunt that
barely went to school that
maybe couldn't read or you know wasn't
the smartest person in the world will
have a very immediate vision of this and
if you ask them they'll probably not
have thought about it and you'll say
something like yeah jesus went up into
heaven of course he went up like where
else is he gonna go like
he he went up and and they haven't
thought about it
it's it's intuitive they they haven't
worked it out and so but the problem is
that in some ways it's
it's not that big of a deal because
their experience of that which is above
them is the proper way to understand the
spiritual hierarchies at the level at
which they're capable of understanding
it now i will admit that in a world of
satellites and a world of spaceships and
of quasars and whatever
this can be difficult because that great
aunt of yours whose intuition about what
is above is actually
right on in terms of her experience of
this hierarchy
can be completely
like their faith can be destroyed by
someone pointing out to the fact that
obviously jesus is not hanging up there
in the atmosphere like he's not he's not
having to watch out for for the
satellites that are coming by or you
know maybe
chatting with the people at the space
station you know and that it's true some
people's faith sadly can be could be
crushed by that and so in a way maybe
this is the time to be a little more
to press a little more the the idea
which you find in the ancients which is
that this is an image to help you
understand the relationship between the
invisible and the visible and it's there
in scripture
already at the outset for example
there are places in the bible where we
say our father in heaven and we don't
flinch when we say that but we also know
that there are places in heaven where it
says the heaven of heavens cannot
contain you and this is also the idea
that the
heaven of heavens that is
the highest heaven the heaven which
makes the heavens we see possible right
where is that it's it's not a place it's
not a place at least in the way that we
think of it right it's the it's the the
the place of places right it's the cause
of place itself or the cause of the or
the of the patterns behind the very
patterns themselves and you see that the
way of talking about god all the time we
say he's the king of kings he's the lord
of lords you know and we try to help you
see that god is obviously not a king
sitting on a throne in the atmosphere
and throwing lightning bolts but
understanding what a king is
might be one of the best ways for you to
understand how the authority of god
works right understanding what a lord is
understanding what like i said what
heaven is is the best way to understand
the manner in which the invisibles move
the visible
and so i hope this has been helpful and
uh and that it helps you understand a
little more what
what
heaven is and if you're interested i
wrote a series of articles almost 10
years ago now
the first one is called most of the time
the earth is flat
and it kind of introduces this way of
thinking the second of one is the second
one is actually called where is heaven
and i address and i use some of the
quotes that i quoted today from dante
from heidegger and uh from a few other
people so if you're interested in that
please check it out and i will talk to
you very soon